do you really like Taylor Swift you
muffin smuggling dragon fart we should
sit down while we are sitting down we
should sit down when we are sitting down
ah gosh why won't let they let you watch
Deadpool Deadpool is like a little dad
pulls a little much for you you know
when you're a little bit older like in
five months no problem
but right now too young I think no no no
no no no no tears this is a tear free
zone okay all right let it out come on
let it out there you go he's okay he's
okay you guys will get to see Deadpool
soon though braless Ryan your friend
your Taylor Swift can you put in a good
word for me
done done what kind of good word do you
want
you don't know do you like Taylor Swift
but we still want to be mouthing any
tips ah yeah you can get kind of
creative with it you know your brothers
getting you mad or something like that
you can say like you know you muffins
smuggling dragon fart something like
that right that's kind of fun the worst
swear that I use like what if I hit my
toe or something I'll save Finnegan's
biscuits mm-hm and that really gets out
all the anger and hate against biscuits
yeah I'm much more hardcore than Rob see
what I like to say how long will it
leave until Deadpool I'm moving Stein's
down together
that's a great question man I'm gonna -
we're all kind of wondering that you
know Hugh Jackman has said he's no
longer gonna play the role of Wolverine
but we'll see what happens if there's a
contracting economy soon no nothing okay
well what's the best thing about being a
movie star well it's good to ask me this
question or not Brian I had a Caesar
salad for breakfast what yeah
the shame 9x wrong with you yeah people
you know outside of Hollywood you know
that's not done yeah but I did it
Brian you have your engine company
what's the funniest thing you have that
then after drinking it funniest thing
I've ever done after drinking from my
own gin company I do have a gin company
called aviation gin ha what's the
funniest thing I've ever done after
drinking it um I don't know I've done a
couple of like in my day I've done a
couple of like you know small viennese
you know a little break and Entering
just you know pick a random house just
say I'm gonna move in there yeah yeah I
don't know I'm lost in your eyes right
now I can't look away you want to have a
staring contest see how long we can go
without blinking
Oh close so close no I'd not like to
breathe breathe come on the daeviation
gin stung historias